you
[Music]
former White House chief tragedy Bannon
is opening up about the leaked Access
Hollywood video that led to a crisis in
from campaign our sixty minutes
interview is the first extensive
conversation with Bannon since he left
the Trump administration a few weeks
before the election a video obtained by
The Washington Post revealed Donald
Trump talking with Billy Bush about
groping women it sent his campaign into
full damage control the weekend after
the video came out mr. Trump met with
his senior advisors Bannon
Reince Priebus and New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie discussed the next steps
in our sixty minutes interview Bannon
explained how the meeting caused
Christie a potential job in the
administration in Trump went around the
room and asked people the percentages he
thought of still winning and what the
recommendation a right start off and
Wright said you have you have two
choices you either drop out right now or
you lose by the biggest landslide in
American political history in Trump with
his humor because that's a great way
that's a great way to start our start a
conversation we went around the room and
you could tell I could tell from the
incoming of politicians and I could tell
from some of the politicians that were
there is that the natural inclination of
politicians are to be so overwhelmingly
stunned and shocked by how the media
comes on you but Trump wasn't that and I
told me is the one around I was the last
guy to speak and I said it's a hundred
percent you have a hundred percent
probability of winning and that's the
first time you seem to have done that at
every point in the campaign when he was
in trouble
asking him to double down on his
rhetoric double down in terms of
appealing to his base apparent appealing
to the American people into the
working-class people in this country
absolutely you know why because decade
was a winner that's why kill him double
down every time and on that day that's
the first time and only time we ever got
upset when he goes come on it's not 100%
I go it's absolutely under percent that
told him why they don't care they do
care about respect for women they do but
but they but and it's not just locker
room talk and it's locker room talk the
Billy Bush thing is locker I'm talking
did you lose confidence of anybody
because they came in at you at that
point and said look we ought to get out
of this race other than Reince Priebus I
mean did your attitude towards those
people who said that they're you're just
absolutely a bully Bush Saturday to me
is
litmus test it's a litmus test and I
said it the other day to general Kelly
during the shawwal thing afterwards it's
a it's a line I remember from the movie
the Wild Bunch
wait Holden uses it right before that
huge gunfight at the end when you side
with a man you side with him okay the
good in the bad you can criticize him
behind but when you side with him you
have to side with him and that's what
Billy Bush weekend showed me Billy Bush
Saturday showed me who really had Donald
Trump's back to play to his better
angels all you had to do and what he did
was go out and continue to talk the
American people people didn't care they
knew Donald Trump was just doing locker
room talk with a guy and they dismissed
it it had no lasting impact on the
campaign yet if you see the mainstream
media that day it was literally he was
falling into Dante's Inferno well you
took names I'm Billy Bush son didn't you
I did I got him I got it you know I'm
Irish I gotta get my black book and I
got him Christie because of Billy Bush
weekend and was was not looked at for a
cabinet position he wasn't there for
young Billy Bush weekend so therefore he
doesn't get a cabinet position I told
him the plane leaves at 11 o'clock in
the morning if you're on the plane
you're on the team didn't make the plane
well there he is I mean he is an
interesting guy to talk to because a he
was a my witness to a lot of stuff B he
has strong opinions and the three he
likes to talk yeah and essentially
enforcing blind loyalty rightfully what
he said you know at a time like that he
said you want to know somebody who's
willing to go forward not stay in the
foxhole to hear him say that about Chris
Christie that him not being on the
president's side eliminated any sort of
cabinet position on the plane or you're
out yeah wow you can see the full report
Sunday on 60 minutes that is at seven
six central right here on CBS